los ministros de exteriores de la unión
europea están a favor de la candidatura
de ucrania al bloque comunitario en la
primera reunión después de que kiev
recibirá el visto bueno de la comisión
europea que recomendó a su candidatura a
ingresar a este bloque su ingreso
entonces depende de kiev ucrania tendría
que implementar reformas importantes en
el campo judicial o la lucha contra la
corrupción por lo que el proceso para
una eventual adhesión de ucrania podría
tomar algunos años atrás la comisión se
espera que el pronunciamiento del
consejo europeo sobre el enlace
intenciones de ucrania el presidente
selenski advirtió que espera una
intensificación de la ofensiva rusa
previa a dicho pronunciamiento la
comisión también recomendó la
candidatura de moldavia pero dejó por
fuera por ahora georgia a georgia uno de
los ciudadanos que ha salido de las
calles para pedir su ingreso a la unión
europea
vamos al lugar entonces a nuestro
segundo invitado al día fernando wilson
doctor en historia y docente en la
universidad adolfo ibáñez en chile
gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 fernando le
preguntó entonces qué tan real es la
posibilidad de ingreso de ucrania a la
unión europea
es un hecho político más que práctico
en términos de capacidad craneana de
insertarse en las economías europeas
por las instituciones de ucrania nas son
particularmente débiles en términos de
solidez democrática corrupción etcétera
y por lo tanto va a ser un viaje largo
el que van a tener que desarrollar antes
de poder incorporarse en términos
prácticos a la unión europea pero por el
otro lado está el hecho político
evidente de la invasión rusa y de la
voluntad europea de transmitir un
mensaje claro una dicha agresión por lo
tanto se le admite en términos de
postulación pero en un proceso
particular probablemente adoc sui
generis en el cual ucrania va a ir
lentamente asumiendo digamos su posición
a medida que sus instituciones puedan
efectivamente estar a la altura de las
circunstancias y puedan realmente
incorporarse y desarrollar un patrón de
relación eficiente con sus contrapartes
europeas continentales claro fernando
hablando de estas reformas y los cambios
que tienen que ser ucrania para poder
realmente ingresar no a la unión europea
cuál es la principal que tendría que
hacer que digamos de inmediato para ver
ese cambio a lo largo del tiempo pues
obviamente esos cambios no en una serie
de la noche a la mañana
primero que nada necesita digamos salir
de esta condición de guerra ya sea
porque se acepte un acuerdo de paz ya
sea porque se retire o lo que fuere
estamos claros que en este momento en
particular es imposible producir ningún
avance real en términos de desarrollo
institucional mientras las ciudades
ucranianas están siendo bombardeadas por
la artillería y misiles rusos ahora
hecho aquello superada esta situación y
ahí viene la gran pregunta si es que
rusia no buscará prolongar este
conflicto en la manera de un conflicto
de baja intensidad
semipermanente como de hecho ocurrió
entre el 2014 y el pasado 23 de febrero
en el donbass
de entrar a todo un proceso de
adecuación que obedecerá la situación
práctica en que se encuentre ucrania en
ese momento los desplazados la
destrucción de su infraestructura
industrial las limitaciones en sus
exportaciones de cereales
el acceso a la energía
recordemos la captura de por lo menos
dos centrales nucleares fundamentales
para la generación eléctrica etcétera
todo ello va a tener un impacto brutal
en términos de la capacidad ucraniana
real de poder conducir esta
modernización institucional
para incorporarse como miembro de pleno
derecho a la unión europea claro y lo
que usted habla digamos hacer una
reconstrucción y algo que tomaría como
también lo dicen muchos expertos de diez
y veinte años en un futuro cercano
digamos si la guerra acabaría
en un mes o en unas semanas que pues
tampoco es un escenario posible por el
momento a mediano plazo realmente
pudiera realizarse esta adhesión de
ucrania o sería mucho más largo
a veces que en términos prácticos para
todos los efectos políticos
en la unión europea ya está siendo
tratada no solamente como miembro de la
unión europea sino que también como un
miembro del otan las transferencias de
armamento las entregas de inteligencia
para todos los efectos prácticos ya se
los considera como parte esta
declaración es más bien un hecho
político en el cual lo que se busca es
de alguna manera manifestar de manera
concreta digamos a los cien días de la
guerra la voluntad europea de no
abandonar a ucrania y de mantener el
rechazo a la actitud agresiva del
régimen de putin en moscú desde esa
forma el objetivo estratégico se
consigue la mejor forma precisamente en
el vídeo que muestran en este momento se
ve a úrsula von der layen de gamos
vestida con los colores de ucrania de
gamo amarillo y azul
reflejando precisamente ese compromiso
político y el punto político que se está
buscando hacer con esta con esta
postulación no hay que entenderlo tanto
como un proceso
práctico administrativo como lo fue por
ejemplo durante décadas la postulación
turca con que la unión europea agonizaba
así es que realmente turquía podría ser
considerada o no un país europeo dio
habían dos sido el adversario de europa
por más de un milenio en ese sentido
digamos el caso ucraniano era establecer
el punto político para
confirmar el apoyo europeo a la
resistencia del régimen selenski de la
democracia ucraniana por imperfecta que
ésta sea frente a la agresión de la
autocracia rusa hablas de por supuesto
uno de los protagonistas dentro de este
conflicto en el que inició mejor dicho
este conflicto también de rusia cómo ve
el kremlin y como el gobierno de
vladímir putin este pronunciamiento de
la unión europea y este de la luz verde
digamos de bueno si tienes la
posibilidad de en algún futuro ingresar
a la unión europea lo vería como una
amenaza y también como usted lo decía
también pudiera ser una estrategia
militar de vladimir putin extender la
guerra lo más que pueda para que este
proceso se siga dilatando y dilatando la
largo
en términos prácticos
el problema real ruso es que su derrota
estratégica ya es un hecho de hecho esto
ya estaba claro a la segunda semana de
la guerra esta no fue la guerra que
vladimir putin esperaba a poder librar
contra contra ucrania que era un
conflicto rápido a través de un golpe de
mano quiere decapitar el gobierno
ucraniano y luego una ocupación
aprovechando el desorden posterior de la
propio gran en una escena así putin hoy
día su mejor apuesta que no es muy buena
tampoco es básicamente prolongar la
guerra porque eso le permite dentro del
escenario político dentro de lo que
podemos ver de del escenario político
ruso que es absolutamente críptico una
escena de con nosotros o contra nosotros
asociando a putin al deseo de
y defender la dignidad de rusia es decir
putin se está envolviendo en la bandera
y está planteando un esquema de yo soy
rusia y todo el que se oponga a mí se
opone a rusia en un en una situación así
obviamente está en su interés que si no
tiene una victoria clara y evidente
bueno mantener el conflicto abierto
porque le permite mantener esa suerte de
dualidad maniquea entre los que lo
apoyan y los que lo rechazan
recordemos también por favor que rusia
nunca ha sido una democracia liberal
representativa nunca ha tenido
estructuras democráticas ha tenido
algunos atisbos electorales ha tenido
algunos atisbos institucionales pero en
términos prácticos su tradición política
es netamente autocrática y por lo tanto
también no tiene una ciudadanía en poder
a lucha digamos por derechos políticos
claros y nítidos
si también seguimos hablando de rusia
porque dice que ucrania está siendo
utilizada por la unión europea está
siendo digamos de alguna forma engañada
por en europea con todo
de el posible ingreso pues habrá el
tiempo lo dirá cuando ingresaría a la
unión europea que tan ciertas estas
afirmaciones de rusia
digamos que refleja de alguna manera la
derrota estratégica de rusia que agrega
este elemento de digamos de una europa
que nos intimida frente a las amenazas
del kremlin
e invita a ucrania a postular
formalmente y que se combina con la
postulación de suecia y finlandia al
ingreso a la otan es decir ya se con el
gran temor ruso que era precisamente
evitar esta suerte de barrera de países
del otan y de la unión europea en torno
a sus fronteras occidentales
se comienza a materializar de manera
práctica
algunos analistas ya hablan directamente
de que se produce una verdadera barrera
de estados eslavos del otan desde el
océano ártico digamos la frontera entre
noruega y finlandia con rusia en el
norte hasta el sur digamos la frontera
rumana y tam búlgara y bueno turca
digamos marcando una verdadera barrera
frente a rusia que separaría a europa
central y occidental del mundo eslavo
eso era exactamente lo que la
geopolítica rusa ha tratado de superar
desde el siglo 16 y claramente es una
derrota en el largo en el largo plazo y
en el sentido profundo de lo que
planteaba inicialmente vladimir putin
entonces la expresión concreta de su
derrota estratégicas